SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. DALY. DODD. DURAZO.
EGGMAN. GLAZER. GONZALEZ. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD. LEHMAN.
MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN. NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. ROTH. RUBIO SEYARTO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB. WIENER.
WILK. A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS.
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY. PLEASE RISE. WE WILL
FIRST BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR CHAPLAIN, SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN. AFTER THAT,
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG.
THANK YOU. WE GATHER IN THE
PRESENCE OF OUR GOD. THE POET
GWENDOLYN BROOKS HAS SAID WE ARE
EACH OTHER'S HARVEST. WE ARE
EACH OTHER'S BUSINESS. WE ARE
EACH OTHER'S MAGNITUDE AND BOND.
LOVING GOD, HOLY MYSTERY. WE
THANK YOU FOR THE ENERGY THAT
DRIVES US TOWARD CREATIVITY AND
ENTWINES OUR LIVES WITH EACH
OTHER. MAY OUR HEARTS BE EVER
MORE HOPEFUL AS WE CONTINUE TO
CREATE THAT BELOVED COMMUNITY
WHERE ALL CAN ENJOY THE THRILL
OF FORGING LIFE AND LOVE IN OUR
PRECIOUS STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME. AMEN YOU
COULD PLACE YOUR HAND OVER YOUR
HEART. REPEAT AFTER ME. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO. WHICH STANDS ONE
NATION UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE,
WITH LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. MEMBERS.
FIRST UP. PRIVILEGES. PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR. AND I'M GOING TO
TAKE THIS PRIVILEGE TO RECOGNIZE
IN THE BACK OF THE CHAMBERS THE
FORMER ASSEMBLYMAN FOR THE 38TH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND MY GOOD
FRIEND DANTE ACOSTA, PLEASE GIVE
A WARM SENATE WELCOME. TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR. WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. NOW WE ARE MOVING TO
MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
THERE ARE FOUR AMENDMENTS AT THE
DESK AND THEY WILL BE DEEMED
ADOPTED ON. THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ARE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES. FILE ITEM 13 A, B 1755.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, PURSUANT TO
JOINT RULE 33.1, JOINT RULE 61
WILL BE SUSPENDED TO ALLOW THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO MEET AND
REPORT AB 1755 AFTER THE
DEADLINE. THIS REQUEST HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
THE CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE. UP FIRST IS SECOND READING
FILE. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 828 3283 1505
2037, 21, OH SEVEN, 25, 74,
1799, 22, 36, BE DEEMED READ.
THANK YOU. UP NEXT, GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT. WE'LL START WITH
FILE ITEM 30. TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO SENATOR GROVE. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES,
THE FILE ITEM 30 IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR FELIX YIP
TO THE APPOINTMENT OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
DOCTOR YIP IS A PRACTICING
NEUROLOGIST, A PROFESSOR OF
MEDICINE AT UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, UC IRVINE,
AND HE PREVIOUSLY SERVED ON THE
BOARD FROM 2013 TO 2022 AND
BRIEFLY IN 2003. HE WAS APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON A50
VOTE. JUNE 26TH AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. SEEING NO MIKES UP,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ADAM AYE.
ALVARADO AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. BECKER.
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY.
AYE. DODD. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN
GLASER. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE.
AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. WHEN AYE.
NILO. AYE. OCHOA AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB WIENER. AYE
WILK. AYE. SENATOR. GROVE MOVES
THE CALL UP. NEXT FILE, ITEM 34.
ONCE AGAIN, WE TURN TO SENATOR
GROVE. MR. PRESIDENT, FILE ITEM
34 IS THE CONFIRMATION OF LEE
ANN EAGER, FOR THE APPOINTMENT
TO THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. MISS EAGER WAS JOINED
THE COMMISSION IN 2020 AND HAS
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS CHAIR.
SHE'S THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF FRESNO COUNTY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION, AND
ALSO SERVED MANY YEARS AS A VERY
SUCCESSFUL ORGANIZATION AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF RAPE
COUNSELING SERVICES IN FRESNO.
SHE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON AUGUST 7TH ON A50
VOTE. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. SEEING NO MIXUP,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. BECKER BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. AYE. DODD
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. MEN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE. OCHOA
BORG. AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO. AYE.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
BECKER. BRADFORD DODD. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. MENGIBAR. SKINNER.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WAHAB. WE
HAVE A FULL HOUSE. AYES 33. NO.
ZERO CONFIRMATION. I MEAN, THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. NOW
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY.
THIRD READING. UP FIRST IS FILE
ITEM 56 AB 2504. YEAH THIS IS
NOT ME. THIS IS THE CHIEF CLERK
SAYING YOU'RE TOO CHATTY. SO
DON'T MAKE IT HARD FOR ME SO
FAR. SO FIRST UP AGAIN IS FILE
ITEM 56, SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2504 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DIXON. AN ACT RELATING TO
STATE GOVERNMENT AND RECOGNIZE
YOU, SENATOR NGUYEN. THANK YOU,
MISTER PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT AB 20 504 ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER DIANNE DIXON.
AB 20 504 WILL RECOGNIZE THE
BLACK ABALONE AS THE OFFICIAL
STATE SEAL. STATE SEASHELL OF
CALIFORNIA. THE BLACK ABALONE IS
UNIQUE TO CALIFORNIA AND HOLDS A
RICH HISTORY. ADDITIONALLY AS AN
ENDANGERED SPECIES, THE BLACK
ABALONE SERVES AS A REMINDER OF
HOW CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND HOW, AS A
STEWARDS OF THE STATE, WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO KEEP OUR
OCEANS CLEAN AND PROTECT THE
CREATURES THAT WE CALL HOME.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES AND NO OPPOSITION. AGAIN,
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND I
VOTE AYE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
NGUYEN. SEEING NO MICROPHONES
UP, THIS IS ACTUALLY ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SO ANY
OBJECTIONS TO THAT? SEEING NONE.
AYES 33. NOES ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. NOW. MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 59 AB 3072. SENATOR RUBIO
WILL BE PRESENTING. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3072
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRI NORIS.
AN ACT RELATING TO CHILD CUSTODY.
YEAH. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE, I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 3072 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS TO
HELP KEEP KIDS SAFE DURING
CUSTODY BATTLES. CURRENT LAW
GENERALLY LIMITS WHEN A COURT
CAN MAKE AN EX PARTE CUSTODY
ORDER, EXCEPT FOR INSTANCES
WHERE THERE IS AN IMMEDIATE RISK
OF HARM TO A CHILD. AB 3072 DOES
TWO THINGS. FIRST, IT SIMPLY
REQUIRES THAT WHEN A COURT IS
DETERMINING IF THERE IS A RISK
OF IMMEDIATE HARM, THEY SHOULD
CONSIDER A PARENT'S ILLEGAL.
THEY SHOULD CONSIDER THE ACCESS
TO ILLEGAL FIREARMS. SECOND, THE
BILL AUTHORIZES THE COURT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE CHILD IS BETTER
SERVED BY LIMITING THE
SUPERVISION, OR BY ORDERING
SUPERVISED OR VIRTUAL
SITUATIONS. THERE IS A CASE IN
SACRAMENTO WHERE A MOTHER LOST
HER THREE LITTLE GIRLS, AND SHE
PLEADED WITH THE COURTS. SHE
KNEW THAT THE HUSBAND EX-HUSBAND
WAS THREATENING TO KILL THEM,
HARM HIMSELF, AND THERE WAS A
LOT OF INSTANCES WHERE THOSE
THREE LITTLE GIRLS SHOULD HAVE
BEEN REMOVED, BUT THEY DID NOT.
THE COURTS DID NOT LISTEN. AND
OF COURSE, THE THREE LITTLE
GIRLS WERE FATALLY SHOT. SO
UNFORTUNATELY, WE NEED TO
IMPLEMENT THIS BILL TO ENSURE
THAT THESE PRECIOUS CHILDREN ARE
PROTECTED. THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. SEEING NO
MIX UP, THIS BILL TWO IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTIONS? SEEING
NONE. AYES 33. NO. ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 71, AB
2403 IS GOING TO BE PRESENTED BY
SENATOR CORTEZ. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2403
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THANK YOU. SENATOR CORTEZ FLOREZ
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
SENATORS, I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB 2403 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA, THE
STUDENT EQUITY AND ACHIEVEMENT
PROGRAM PROVIDES $450 MILLION
ANNUALLY TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO HELP
SCHOOLS ELIMINATE ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS FOR STUDENTS FROM
TRADITIONALLY UNDERREPRESENTED
GROUPS. AS A CONDITION OF THIS
FUNDING, A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS ARE REQUIRED TO
MAINTAIN A STUDENT EQUITY PLAN
THAT SPECIFIES HOW THESE DOLLARS
ARE SPENT. ULTIMATELY, THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT STUDENT VOICES
ARE HEARD AND ACCOUNTED FOR WHEN
ALLOCATING STUDENT EQUITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM FUNDS. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU SIR. SEEING
NO MIXUP, THIS BILL IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTIONS? SEEING NONE. AYES
33. NOES ZERO. NOW MEMBERS, WE
ARE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 76 AB
6866 B PRESENTED BY SENATOR
ASHBY. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 866 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO. AN ACT
RELATING TO JUVENILES. SENATOR
ASHBY. MR. PRESIDENT, YOU ARE
DOING A GREAT JOB. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. I RISE TO PRESENT AB 866
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYWOMAN
RUBIO. AB 866 WILL CLARIFY THAT
YOUTH IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM,
AGE 16 AND OLDER MAY CONSENT FOR
MEDICALLY ASSISTED SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT WITHOUT NEEDING COURT
APPROVAL. THIS BILL WILL CLARIFY
THE ROLE OF COURT OVERSIGHT IN
THESE CASES. THIS MEASURE
PROVIDES CERTAINTY FOR FOSTER
YOUTH WHO COULD BENEFIT FROM AND
PROACTIVELY SEEK MEDICALLY
ASSISTED TREATMENT, JUST AS
OTHERS OUTSIDE OF THE SYSTEM
ALREADY CAN. THE MEASURE HAS A
COALITION OF FOSTER YOUTH
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT, HAS SEEN
NO OPPOSITION, AND HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ASHBY. ANYONE ELSE
WANTING TO SPEAK ON THIS MATTER?
SEEING NONE. THIS IS ACTUALLY
REQUIRES A ROLL CALL VOTE. SO,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GIL NO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY DODD. AYE.
DURAZO. I. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LYMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. AYE. OCHOA NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SATO. NO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS BECKER. BRADFORD DALLEY.
MENGIBAR NGUYEN. NÓ SKINNER.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WAHAB. AYES
26. NO. SIX MEASURE PASSES NOW.
MEMBERS. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
78. AB 2630 WILL BE PRESENTED
ONCE AGAIN BY SENATOR RUBIO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2630 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA. AN ACT RELATING TO PUPIL
HEALTH. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB 2630 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. THIS
CRITICAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
WOULD EXTEND KINDERGARTNERS ORAL
HEALTH ASSESSMENTS TO THE
STUDENTS ENROLLING IN
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN. TOOTH
DECAY IS A COMMON, PREVENTABLE
DISEASE OF CHILDHOOD THAT CAN BE
THAT CAN CAUSE PAIN PROBLEMS.
EATING ABSENTEEISM, THAT THEN
LATER CREATES EDUCATIONAL
CONCERNS. IF NOT ADDRESSED EARLY
THROUGH SCREENING AND
INTERVENTION. VÌ BY NEXT YEAR
2025 2026 SCHOOL YEAR, WE EXPECT
TYPEKIT PROGRAMS WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS
IN THE STATE. THESE ASSESSMENTS
WILL BE ESSENTIAL TO HELP
IDENTIFY CAVITIES AND OTHER ORAL
HEALTH NEEDS AT AN EARLY AGE.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR RUBIO. ANYONE WANT TO
SPEAK ON THIS MEASURE? SEEING
NONE, THIS IS AGAIN ELIGIBLE FOR
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTIONS? SEEING NONE. AYES
33. NOES ZERO. I HAVE SOME
FABULOUS NEWS FOR YOU MEMBERS.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A 15 MINUTE
BREAK. DO NOT LEAVE THE BUILDING
AND WE WILL RECONVENE AT 10:45
A.M.
APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY.
MEMBERS. THE BATTERY WENT OUT IN
MY PHONE. SO THAT'S WHY IT WAS
MORE THAN 60S. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE ON ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING FILE ITEM 100 ÁP 2015.
AND PRESENTING WILL BE SENATOR
ROTH. AND I SEE HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2015 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHABO. AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALING ARTS. SENATOR ROTH, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL HAS TO DO
WITH NURSE CREDENTIALING FOR
NURSING SCHOOL PROGRAMS. THE
CURRENT PROCESS OF NURSE
APPROVAL FOR FACULTY MEMBERS
REQUIRES A SPECIFIC NURSING
PROGRAM TO APPLY FOR FACULTY
APPROVAL, ESSENTIALLY AT THE
POINT WHERE THE CANDIDATE HAS
BEEN PROVIDED AN OFFER LETTER.
SO IF THERE ARE PROBLEMS WITH
CREDENTIALING AFTER THE OFFER
LETTER HAS BEEN PROVIDED, THE
HIRING PROCESS IS DELAYED. AMONG
OTHER THINGS, THIS BILL FIXES
THIS BY ALLOWING NURSES TO APPLY
DIRECTLY TO THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING FOR APPROVAL.
THE BOARD CREDENTIALS THE NURSE.
THE BOARD MAINTAINS A POOL OF
CREDENTIALED NURSES, THUS MAKING
THE CREDENTIALS PORTABLE AND
REMOVING AN ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN TO FACULTY. HIRING IN OUR
NURSING SCHOOLS IN THIS STATE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ROTH. ANY MIX
UP TO DISCUSS THIS MEASURE
SAYING NONE. THIS REQUIRES A
ROLL CALL. SO SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. BECKER.
BLAKE SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY DODD. AYE. DURAZO EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR MEN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. WHEN NO. NILO AYE.
OKUBO. AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. CIERTO. NO SKINNER.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB WIENER. AYE
WILK. AYE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL ATKINS. BECKER
BRADFORD. DALLEY DURAZO. AYE.
GROVE MENGIBAR. SKINNER.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. WAHAB
SECRETARY. CAN WE CALL THE ROLL
ONE FINAL TIME? ALVARADO. GILL
AYE. ATKINS BECKER. BRADFORD
DALLY. GROVE NO. MENGIBAR.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WAHAB.
AYES 28 NOES FOUR. MEASURE.
PASSES NOW CONTINUING ON FILE
ITEM 102. AB 2094. EXCUSE ME.
BEING PRESENTED BY SENATOR
HURTADO. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2094 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LARA. AN ACT RELATING TO
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES. SENATOR,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, TODAY
I RISE TO PRESENT AB 2094. IT'S
A DISTRICT BILL THAT PROVIDES AN
EXEMPTION TO THE GENERAL
PROHIBITION AGAINST THE
CONSUMPTION AND SALE OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES ON SCHOOL
PROPERTY FOR SPORTING AND
CONCERT EVENTS AT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN BAKERSFIELD. THE BILL
HAS NO NO VOTES, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, SEEING NO
MIX UP. THIS BILL IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTIONS TO THAT? SEEING NONE.
AYES 33. NOES ZERO. MR. CARRIES
NOW MEMBERS. MOVING ON TO FINAL
ITEM 111 AB3 THOUSAND 85 IS
GOING TO BE PRESENTED BY SENATOR
CORTESE, SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 3085 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIBSON. AN ACT RELATING
TO VEHICLES. SENATOR CORTESE.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS, I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 3085 ON BEHALF OF
OUR COLLEAGUE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIBSON. THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS. THE BILL AUTHORIZES
A JUDGE TO IMPOUND A PERSON'S
VEHICLE FOR PARTICIPATING IN A
MOTOR VEHICLE SPEED CONTEST
PRIOR TO CONVICTION. THE BILL
MIRRORS EXISTING LAW FOR
RECKLESS DRIVING, STREET
TAKEOVERS, AND VEHICLE SPEED
CONTESTS. AS WE ALL KNOW, HAVE
BECOME MORE AND MORE DANGEROUS.
UNSANCTIONED EVENTS WHERE UNRULY
CROWDS AND VEHICLES BLOCK AND
TAKE OVER PUBLIC STREETS AND
INTERSECTIONS IN ORDER TO ENGAGE
IN RECKLESS VEHICULAR STUNTS AND
OTHER DISORDERLY BEHAVIOR. THESE
TAKEOVERS CAUSE NOISE POLLUTION,
TRAFFIC OBSTRUCTIONS, PROPERTY
DAMAGE. ET CETERA. ET CETERA.
THEY ARE ALSO SERIOUS PUBLIC
SAFETY HAZARDS AND PROMOTE A
RECKLESS CULTURE OF LAWLESSNESS
BY ENFORCING A 30 DAY
IMPOUNDMENT OF THE VEHICLE AT A
POINT AND A POINT ON THE
INDIVIDUAL'S RECORD. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. I'D
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS ON THIS MEASURE? SEEING
NO MIX UP, THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTIONS? SEEING NONE. AYES
33. NO. ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
NOW, MEMBERS, MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 112 AB 2146 BEING PRESENTED
BY SENATOR RUBIO. AND IT LOOKS
LIKE SHE'S PREPARED. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2146
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ. AN
ACT RELATING TO PRODUCT SAFETY.
FOR SURE. SENATOR RUBIO. YES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE, TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2146 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FREDDY RODRIGUEZ,
WHICH WOULD BAN THE SALE OF
WEARABLE PERSONAL FLOTATION
DEVICES THAT ARE NOT APPROVED BY
THE US COAST GUARD. THIS BILL IS
LIMITED TO PRODUCTS DESIGNED TO
BE WORN OR ATTACHED TO THE BODY
OF AN INFANT. LAST YEAR, A YOUNG
CHILD IN MY DISTRICT SUFFERED
FROM A TRAGIC, NON-FATAL
DROWNING INCIDENT, AND WHILE HE
SURVIVED, HE AND HIS FAMILY HAVE
STARTED A LONG AND COSTLY
PROCESS OF RECOVERING AND
ADAPTING TO LIVING WITH NEW
DISABILITIES. THIS BILL IS
CRITICAL. IT AIMS TO HELP
ELIMINATE DROWNING TRAGEDIES
BECAUSE NOBODY SHOULD ENDURE THE
PAIN AND SUFFERING OF LOSING A
CHILD, ESPECIALLY IF IT COULD BE
PREVENTED. WHILE THE STATE HAS
TAKEN SEVERAL STEPS TO PROMOTE
WATER SAFETY AND PREVENT
DROWNING INCIDENTS, THERE ARE
CONSUMER PRODUCTS SUCH AS WATER,
WINGS AND FLOATIES ON THE MARKET
THAT FAIL TO KEEP OUR CHILDREN
SAFE WHILE IN THE WATER. MANY
EXPERTS, INCLUDING CDC, THE US
CONSUMER PRODUCT SAFETY
COMMISSION AND THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS, HAVE
EXPRESSED THE DANGERS OF THESE
PRODUCTS. THEREFORE, THIS BILL
PROPOSES A BAN OF THESE FLOATING
DEVICES DESIGNED AGAIN TO BE
WORN BY INFANTS. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. ANY MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THE SUBJECT? SEEING
NONE, THIS TWO IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTIONS? SEEING NONE. AYES
33. NØ ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 131 AB 1947, GOING TO
BE PRESENTED BY SENATOR LIMÓN
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. THE
ASSEMBLY BILL, 1947 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US. AN ACT
RELATING TO EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION. SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES, I
RISE TO PRESENT AB 1947, A BILL
THAT WOULD EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
STAFF TRAINING DAYS FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND ALLOCATE ONE OF
THESE DAYS FOR DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNERS TRAINING AB 1947 BUILDS
ON OUR PROGRESS MADE IN
SUPPORTING MORE DUAL LANGUAGE BY
HELPING OUR EDUCATORS CATER TO
THE LEARNING NEEDS OF OUR
CHILDREN. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR.
ANY MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK?
SEEING NONE, THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTIONS? SEEING NONE. AYES
33. NOES ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
NOW, MEMBERS, MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 153 AB 2698. I'M GOING TO
BE PRESENTED BY SENATOR DALLI.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2698 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
AN ACT RELATING TO HIGHWAYS.
SENATOR DALLI, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2698 AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TY TAU, WHICH PROPOSES TO
DESIGNATE A PORTION OF HIGHWAY
405 AS LITTLE SAIGON FREEWAY.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO HONOR AND
RECOGNIZE THIS SIGNIFICANT
CULTURE AND HISTORICAL IMPACTS
OF LITTLE SAIGON COMMUNITY. THE
AREA IS PRIMARILY LOCATED IN THE
WESTMINSTER GARDEN GROVE AND
FOUNTAIN VALLEY. IT IS THE HEART
OF THE VIETNAMESE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR DALLI,
ANY MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK?
SEEING NONE, THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTIONS? SEEING NONE. AYES 33
NOES. ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. NOW,
MEMBERS, MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
167 AB 3158 IS GOING TO BE
PRESENTED BY SENATOR CORTESE. I
SEE THAT HE'S READY. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3158
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. AN
ACT RELATING TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. WELL, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND COLLEAGUES. TODAY
I AM HERE TO PRESENT AB 3158 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN. THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
WEST VALLEY MISSION COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT UNTIL JULY 1ST,
2030, TO PROVIDE FREE COLLEGE TO
THEIR STUDENTS BY WAIVING
TUITION FEES. I'M VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THE BILL AND THE SITUATION.
THE COLLEGE DISTRICTS IN MY
DISTRICT 15TH SENATE DISTRICT.
THE SOARING COST OF LIVING AS WE
KNOW, HAS BEEN PARTICULARLY
CHALLENGING FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. AND THIS BILL
PUTS SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
RESOURCES BACK INTO STUDENT'S
POCKETS. WEST VALLEY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT FUNDED A
COLLEGE PROMISE SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM THROUGH THEIR
UNRESTRICTED GENERAL FUND. THEY
ARE WILLING AND ABLE TO MEET
THEIR STUDENTS WHERE THEY ARE,
AND I'M PROUD TO COAUTHOR THIS
BILL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR CORTESE, ANY MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE, THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTIONS? SEEING
NONE. AYES 33. NO'S ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. WILL BE IN
RECESS FOR 15 MINUTES. PLEASE
RETURN. NOW. GREAT NEWS.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
SLIGHT PAUSE. WE WILL, WE WILL,
WE'LL RECONVENE AT 11:20 A.M.
PLEASE DON'T LEAVE THE CAPITOL.
AND WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO START
PROMPTLY AT 1120. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
WELCOME BACK. MEMBERS I SEE THAT
SENATOR NEAL MAIOLO IS MAIOLO.
SO FLOOR IS YOURS, SIR. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I MOVE TO
ADJOURN. SERIOUSLY. YEAH, YEAH,
THAT'S OUT OF ORDER. MR.
PRESIDENT, THE MOTION IS OUT OF
ORDER BECAUSE WE HAVE AN ITEM ON
CALL. AND WHEN THINGS ARE ON,
CALL TO ADJOURN IS OUT OF ORDER.
SO, SENATOR NIELLO, TO JUST
EXPOUND ON WHAT I. YOUR MOTION
IS OUT OF ORDER BECAUSE WE HAVE
ITEMS ON CALL, SO WE CANNOT
ADJOURN. SO I WANTED TO GIVE YOU
A FULL EXPLANATION FOR THAT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING
ON TO ITEM 171 AB 3221. THE
PRESENTER IS SENATOR RUBIO. I
CAN SEE SENATOR RUBIO IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 3221 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PELLERIN. AN ACT RELATING
TO RECORDS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE, I RISE TO PRESENT
AB 3221 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PELLERIN. AB 3221 WILL
IMPROVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE'S ABILITY TO
ENFORCE OUR HEALTH ACCESS LAWS
AND REMOVE PROCEDURAL HURDLES TO
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT. THIS BILL PROVIDES
THAT HEALTH PLANS MUST FURNISH
RECORDS TO DM HCPS IN A
DIGITALLY SEARCHABLE FORMAT WHEN
POSSIBLE, AND IT ALSO CLARIFIES
THAT DMHC HAS THE POWER TO
PENALIZE PLANS IF THEY FAIL TO
RESPOND TO RECORD REQUESTS FULLY
OR IN A TIMELY MANNER. THIS BILL
PASSED EACH COMMITTEE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR RUBIO. ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK? SEEING NO MICS
UP, SECRETARY, CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL
ARCHULETA. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS.
BECKER. BLAKE SPEER. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALI
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN.
AYE. GLASER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE JONES. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. WHEN I. NILO. AYE OCHOA.
BOGH. AYE PADILLA. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB WIENER. WILK AYE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ATKINS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS. BECKER
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD.
DALLY AYE. GROVE MENGIBAR.
PADILLA AYE. SKINNER SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WAHAB. WIENER AYE. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ONE FINAL TIME.
ALVARADO. GILL ATKINS. BECKER.
BRADFORD GROVE. I MENGIBAR
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WAHAB. ALL RIGHT. I AYES 32.
NOES ZERO. MEASURE PASSES UP.
NEXT FILE ITEM 183 AB 2174. THE
PRESENTER IS SENATOR ASHBY. I
SEE THAT SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2174 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY. AN ACT RELATING TO
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES. SENATOR
ASHBY, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2174 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGAR CURRY. AB 2174
ALLOWS CRAFT BREWERS TO APPLY
FOR AND OBTAIN PERMITS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOL AND
BEVERAGE CONTROL TO SELL THEIR
BEER AT LIMITED SPECIAL EVENTS.
THE BILL SUPPORTS LOCAL JOBS AND
BUSINESSES, AND ALLOWS
COMMUNITIES TO SUPPORT THEIR
LOCAL BREWERIES. I RESPECTFULLY
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. ANY SENATORS WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THIS SUBJECT? SEEING NO
MIX UP, THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTIONS? SEEING NONE. AYES
33. NO. ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
NOW, MEMBERS, MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 186 AB 1936. I SEE THAT
SENATOR RUBIO IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL, 1936 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES. AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. SENATOR
RUBIO, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
1936, AND I'M A PROUD COAUTHOR
TO THIS BILL BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES. ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH, MORE THAN 1 IN 5
PREGNANT CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCE
ANXIETY OR DEPRESSION. IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE DO MORE TO
SUPPORT WOMEN. THIS IMPORTANT
BILL WILL INCREASE ACCESS TO
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
SCREENINGS BY ENSURING MOTHERS
ARE PROVIDED ACCESS TO THESE
SCREENINGS, BOTH DURING
PREGNANCY AND AT LEAST ONCE
AFTER GIVING BIRTH. THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT,
HAS NO NO VOTES IN BOTH HOUSES,
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR RUBIO. ANY SENATORS
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS? SEEING
NO MIX UP, THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTIONS TO ONE? SEEING NONE.
AYES 33. NÓ ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS. MOVING ON NOW
TO FILE ITEM 187, WHICH IS AB
2340, AGAIN, BEING PRESENTED BY
SENATOR RUBIO WHO'S READY TO GO.
SO WITH THAT SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2340 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA, AN ACT TO
MEDI-CAL. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, I
RISE TO PRESENT AB 2340 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA, A BILL
THAT WOULD PROVIDE YOUTH AND
FAMILIES AND MEDI-CAL WITH
CRITICAL INFORMATION ABOUT THE
SERVICES CURRENTLY AVAILABLE AND
RECOMMENDED FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH. THIS BILL WILL MAKE SURE
THESE MATERIALS ARE PROVIDED IN
A TIMELY MANNER, AND IT WILL
CLARIFY WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROVIDING THESE MATERIALS. IT
WILL ALSO REQUIRE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT WITH MATERIALS
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED FOR OUR
YOUTH. THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR. ANY MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK? SEEING NO MIX
UP, THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTIONS? SEEING NONE. AYES 33
NO'S ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. NOW,
MEMBERS, MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
196 AB 2017 A BILL FROM
ASSEMBLYMAN GRAYSON GOING TO BE
PRESENTED BY SENATOR CABALLERO.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2017 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON. AN ACT RELATING TO
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS. SENATOR,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2017 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON, WHICH WILL HELP TO
PREVENT FEE CREEP IN OR CREEPING
FEES IN THE BANKING INDUSTRY BY
PROHIBITING STATE CHARTERED
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS FROM
CHARGING A NON-SUFFICIENT FUND
OR NSF FEE TO A CONSUMER FOR A
TRANSACTION DECLINED
INSTANTANEOUSLY OR NEAR
INSTANTANEOUSLY. THIS BILL WOULD
CODIFY IN STATE LAW A RULE
PROPOSED BY THE CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION BUREAU IN
JANUARY IN ORDER TO PROACTIVELY
SET REGULATIONS TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS FROM ABUSIVE
PRACTICES. AB 2017 WILL REIN IN
JUNK FEES AND PROTECT
FINANCIALLY VULNERABLE CONSUMERS
FROM CHARGES THAT CAN'T AFFORD.
THIS BILL CURRENTLY HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION, HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD. CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILA. AYE. OKUBO. AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS BECKER.
BRADFORD. DALLEY GLAZER. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. JONES AYE. MENGIBAR.
NGUYEN. AYE. CIERTO. AYE.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WAHAB.
AYES 32. NO. ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. OKAY OKAY. UP NEXT, FILE
ITEM 201 AB 31 4748. EXCUSE ME.
PRESENTING IS SENATOR NIELLO. I
SEE THAT HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3148 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN. AN ACT RELATING TO
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS. SENATOR,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT
AB 3148 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMAN
CHEN. CURRENTLY, PAYDAY LOAN
LENDERS ARE REQUIRED TO PAY
LICENSING FEES BASED UPON THE
NUMBER OF BRICK AND MORTAR
LOCATIONS THE LICENSEE OPERATES
IN CALIFORNIA. IN RECENT YEARS,
THE NUMBER OF THESE BRICK AND
MORTAR LOCATIONS HAVE DECREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY. WHILE TOTAL
TRANSACTIONS HAVE ALSO
DECREASED. THE NUMBER OF ONLINE
TRANSACTIONS HAS GROWN BOTH
ONLINE AND IN-STORE.
TRANSACTIONS ARE LEGAL AND
REGULATED BY DFP, BUT BASING
FEES ON THE NUMBER OF LOCATIONS
THEY OPERATE IN THE STATE, NOT
BASED UPON THEIR VOLUME OF
BUSINESS THAT THEY CONDUCT IN
CALIFORNIA, HAS LED TO AN
INEQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF
COSTS. THIS BILL CHANGES THIS BY
REQUIRING DFP TO ASSESS FEES TO
PAYDAY LOAN LICENSEES BASED UPON
THEIR VOLUME OF BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA, AS OPPOSED TO THE
NUMBER OF LOCATIONS. THIS BILL
HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION. I REFLECT
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I VOTE
AYE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK?
SEEING NONE, THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTIONS? SEEING NONE. AYES
33. NOES ZERO. NOW MEMBERS,
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 207 AB
3276 BY ASSEMBLYMAN RAMOS, I SEE
THAT SENATOR HURTADO IS PREPARED
TO PRESENT. SO, SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3276
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. AN ACT
RELATING TO TRIBAL GAMING AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
HURTADO, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. TODAY
I'M PRESENTING AB 3276, A BILL
THAT WOULD RATIFY THE GAMING
COMPACT ENTERED INTO BETWEEN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE TULE
RIVER INDIAN TRIBE OF
CALIFORNIA, TULE RIVER HAS JUST
RECENTLY CELEBRATED ITS 28TH
ANNIVERSARY IN 2024 AND IS ONE
OF THE LARGEST EMPLOYERS IN
TULARE COUNTY. GAMING COMPACTS
CAME AS A RESULT OF A HISTORIC,
HARD FOUGHT STRUGGLE TO
RECOGNIZE TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY AND
FORGE A PATH FORWARD WITH
TOWARDS SELF-SUFFICIENCY, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WANTING TO
SPEAK? SENATOR GROVE? THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I TOO WOULD LIKE
AN AYE VOTE ON AB 3276 RAMOS
PRESENTED BY SENATOR HURTADO, MY
NEIGHBORING LEGISLATOR THAT
REPRESENTS THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
TULE RIVER IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
TRIBE. NOT THAT THEY'RE ALL NOT
THERE. I THINK THEY'RE ALL
REALLY AWESOME INDIVIDUALS THAT
PROVIDE JOBS AND A BENEFIT TO
OUR COMMUNITIES. AND SO
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AND I
VOTE FOR 32, 76. ALL RIGHT. ANY
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WANTING TO
WEIGH IN? SEEING NONE. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
ANY OBJECTIONS? SEEING NONE.
AYES 33. NÓ ZERO ON ON THE
MEASURE AND AYES 33. NÓ ZERO ON
THE URGENCY. NOW MEMBERS. MOVING
ON TO ITEM 214 AB 2270 BY
ASSEMBLYMAN MAIENSCHEIN
PRESENTING. SENATOR LOWMAN, I
SEE THAT SHE'S UP AND RARING TO
GO. MR. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2270 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AN ACT TO
HEALING ARTS. SENATOR, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU. PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS AB 2270 AIMS TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES AND THE
WIDESPREAD MISCONCEPTION
SURROUNDING MENOPAUSE, WHICH
LEADS TO A LACK OF UNDERSTANDING
FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING MENOPAUSE
AND DELAYS IN RECEIVING
APPROPRIATE CARE. THIS BILL
HOPES TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THIS AND ALSO INCLUDES A
COURSE ON MENOPAUSE AND MENTAL,
PHYSICAL HEALTH TO SATISFY
CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR PROFESSIONALS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR. ANY
OTHER SENATORS WISHING TO SPEAK?
SEEING NO MIX UP THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTIONS? SEEING
NONE. AYES 33. NÓ ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS FIVE MORE BILLS
TO GO, AND THEN WE'LL HAVE LUNCH
AVAILABLE TO YOU IN THE MADI
LOUNGE FOLLOWING SESSION TODAY.
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
218 AB 1830. AGAIN, SENATOR
LIMÓN. MR. SECRETARY. TO 17, ARE
YOU DOING THREE IN A ROW? THAT'S
IMPRESSIVE. OKAY. FILE ITEM 217
FOR MAIENSCHEIN AB 2581.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2581 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALING ARTS LARA SHORES. THANK
YOU, PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS ARE AMONG THE MOST
COMMON COMPLICATION OF PREGNANCY
AND BIRTH, IMPACTING 1 IN 5
PEOPLE, 75% OF PEOPLE IMPACTED
BY MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS REMAIN UNTREATED,
INCREASING THE RISK OF LONG TERM
NEGATIVE IMPACTS. AB 2581 WOULD
REQUIRE VARIOUS HEALTH AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH LICENSING
BOARDS TO CONSIDER, INCLUDING A
COURSE ON MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR,
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK? SEEING NONE, THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTIONS? SEEING
NONE. AYES 33. NOES ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 218 AB 1830. AGAIN
PRESENTED BY SENATOR LIMÓN. SHE
APPEARS READY. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1830 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA. AN ACT
RELATING TO FOOD. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU. MEMBERS. AB
1830 SUPPORTS HEALTHY
PREGNANCIES BY EXPANDING
MANDATORY FOLIC ACID
FORTIFICATION TO CORN MASA TO
PREVENT DEFECTS. DAILY
CONSUMPTION OF FOLIC ACID
DECREASES THE RISK OF NEURAL
TUBE DEFECTS, SPECIFICALLY
SPINAL BIFIDA, BY MORE THAN
HALF. THIS BILL ASKS FOR THE
MANDATORY FORTIFICATION OF MASA
THROUGH AB 1830, WILL PREVENT
NEW MOTHERS AND PARENTS FROM
LOSING CHILDREN TO NEURAL TUBE
DEFECTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE. THANK YOU. SENATOR. ANY
MIX UP I SEE, SENATOR DURAZZO,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH
THOSE OF US WHO HAD CONCERNS. I
REPRESENT EAST LOS ANGELES,
WHICH IS ACTUALLY THE I THINK
THE TORTILLA CAPITAL, AT LEAST,
OF CALIFORNIA, MAYBE OF THE
COUNTRY, AND, UNDERSTOOD AND
ALLOWED FOR AN HEIRLOOM PRODUCT
WHICH ALSO USES ANCESTRAL YET
HIGH QUALITY METHODS, WHICH IS
VOLCANIC ROCK AND LIMESTONE TO
GRIND THE CORN. THIS IS A METHOD
HAS BEEN USED FOR THOUSANDS OF
YEARS AND IN PARTICULAR, I WANT
TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO THE OWNER
OF LA PRINCESITA TORTILLA MAKER
ENRIQUE RODRIGUEZ IS THE SECOND
GENERATION OWNER OF THIS OF THIS
BUSINESS. I WANT TO THANK HIM
FOR HIS INVOLVEMENT AND HIS
EXPERTISE, AND I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR DURAZO.
SEEING NO OTHER MICS UP, SENATOR
LEÓN, YOU MAY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. WITH THAT
SECRETARY, CALL THE ROLL. ADRIN
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. BECKER.
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
WHEN I. NILO. AYE. OCHOA BORG.
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. AYE RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO AYE. SKINNER. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBER. ALAN AYE. ATKINS.
BECKER. BRADFORD. MENGIBAR.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WAHAB.
AYES 33. NO. ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
TWO. 19 AB 2251. I SEE THAT
SENATOR STERN IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2251 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNOLLY. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUPIL INSTRUCTION. SENATOR
STERN. FLOOR IS YOURS. YES.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AB
TWO. AB 2251 WILL HELP STUDENTS
WHO MISS SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF
TIME DUE TO MENTAL OR PHYSICAL
ILLNESS TO STAY IN STEP WITH
THEIR PEERS AND GRADUATE ON
TIME. THIS BILL MAKES IT
EXPLICITLY CLEAR THAT A SCHOOL
DISTRICT CAN, ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS, ALLOW STUDENTS TO
GRADUATE ON TIME BY MEETING THE
STATE'S REQUIREMENT AND MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN
THE PROCESS. WE KNOW GRADUATION
IS VERY IMPORTANT, AND WE DON'T
WANT TO LET ILLNESS HOLD
STUDENTS BACK. SO THIS BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION, BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK? SEEING NO MIX UP. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTIONS? SEEING
NONE. AYES 33. NÓ ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FINAL ITEM
227 AB 1296 BEING PRESENTED BY
SENATOR DODD. AND YOU SEE THAT
HE'S READY. SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1296 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. AN ACT
RELATING TO BAR PILOTS. SENATOR
DODD. I WOULD SAY IT'S GOOD
AFTERNOON. NOW MR. PRESIDENT,
AND MEMBERS AB 1296 PROHIBITS
STATE REGULATIONS FROM REQUIRING
OR COMPELLING THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAR PILOTS TO REPLACE THREE
SPECIFIED PILOT STATION BOATS
UNLESS THE REGULATION AUTHORIZES
THE REPLACEMENT OF A STATION
BOAT ONCE IT HAS REACHED THE END
OF ITS USEFUL SERVICE LIFE.
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD,
COMMERCIAL AIRCRAFT REGULATIONS,
EFFECTIVE DECEMBER 31ST, WILL
WILL RENDER THESE SERVICES
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE. THIS BILL
PROPOSES A VIABLE PATHWAY TO
ACHIEVE CARB COMPLIANCE. THIS
ALLOWS SUFFICIENT TIME TO
COLLECT THE NECESSARY FUNDS TO
BUILD NEW CARB COMPLIANT BOATS.
1296 WILL ENSURE THAT THE
ECONOMIC HEALTH AND STABILITY OF
THE PILOTED SYSTEM, WHILE
ALIGNING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. THANK YOU
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DODD. ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISHING
TO WEIGH IN? SEEING NO MIX UP?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. AYE DODD.
AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. MIN
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NILO AYE.
OCHOA AYE. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO
AYE. SKINNER. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
WIENER. WILK AYE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ATKINS. BECKER BRADFORD.
JONES MENGIBAR. MEN WHEN I.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WAHAB. WIENER AYE. SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE FINAL TIME. ALAN ATKINS.
BECKER BRADFORD. JONES MENGIBAR.
MIN SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WAHAB. ALL RIGHT. AYES. 30. NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. ALL
RIGHT. UP NEXT IS FILE ITEM. 293
AB 2899 PRESENTING A SENATOR
ROTH. I SEE THAT HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2899 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL. AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH FACILITIES. SENATOR ROTH,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. THIS BILL WILL
BRING GREATER TRANSPARENCY TO
HOW THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE TO
COMPLAINTS REGARDING VIOLATIONS
OF CALIFORNIA'S NURSE TO PATIENT
RATIO LAW. IN PARTICULAR, THE
BILL WILL SUPPORT WORKPLACE
SAFETY EFFORTS AND IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY BY REQUIRING CDPH
TO CONCURRENTLY NOTIFY BOTH THE
HOSPITAL AND THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
REPORTED THE VIOLATION, ALONG
WITH THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGENT OR REPRESENTATIVE,
REGARDING THE ACTION TO BE TAKEN
FOR SUBSTANTIATED VIOLATIONS.
THE BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
NO OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTED. I VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR ROTH, ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK? SEEING NO
MIXUP. SECRETARY, CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER.
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ
AYE. DALLY AYE. DALLY. AYE DODD.
AYE. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
WIENER AYE. WILK SALLY. AYE
DALLY. AYE. TO KNOW, MR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS. BECKER
BLAKE. SPEER. I BRADFORD. JONES
AYE. MENGIBAR. NGUYEN NILO.
OCHOA. BOGH SUGIARTO. SKINNER
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WAHAB WILK.
AYES 27. NOES ONE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME, WE ARE
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON FILE
ITEM 30. GOVERNOR. GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
BECKER, BRADFORD. CABALLERO. Ã
DODD. AYE AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER AYE. MANYAVAR SKINNER.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS BOB. AYES 33.
NO ZERO. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. RIGHT NOW WE'RE
MOVING BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. I SEE SENATOR
GLAZER IS UP. PLEASE SHARE.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
YOU'RE DOING A FANTASTIC JOB
TODAY. I'D LIKE TO, AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, I'D LIKE
TO REMOVE AB 1034 WILSON FROM
THE INACTIVE FILE. THANK YOU
SIR. ANY OTHER ITEMS UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. SEEING
NONE, MR. PRO TEM, I AM HAPPY TO
REPORT THAT IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS, THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
PRESIDENT TODAY FOR ALL OF HIS
WORK. THANK YOU SO MUCH. HE WILL
BE BACK AND READY TO GO NEXT
WEEK AS WELL. WE ACCOMPLISHED 25
BILLS TODAY FOR THE WEEK. IF WE
INCLUDE TOMORROW, WE'LL HIT
ABOUT 140 TO 150. THAT ONLY
LEAVES US ABOUT 4000 TO DO NEXT
WEEK. SO, IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, A
LITTLE BIT OF A PREVIEW OF NEXT
WEEK. MEMBERS SHOULD BE PREPARED
MONDAY, TUESDAY, WEDNESDAY TO
WORK LATE. THAT MEANS PAST 10:30
P.M. ON MONDAY, TUESDAY,
WEDNESDAY. SO WE'LL BE IN
SESSION AT 2:00 ON MONDAY,
WORKING LATE MONDAY, TUESDAY,
WEDNESDAY. SO JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT FOLKS ARE PREPARED,
HYDRATED AND BRING ON THE
CAFFEINE TOMORROW. THANKS TO THE
WORK THAT THIS BODY HAS DONE.
WE'RE GOING TO ONLY BE IN
SESSION FOR ABOUT AN HOUR, HOUR
AND 15 MINUTES TOMORROW. REASON
BEING IS THE VAST MAJORITY OF
BILLS THAT ARE IN FRONT OF THIS
BODY NOW ARE AWAITING
AMENDMENTS, SO WE'LL EXHAUST
WHAT, WHAT'S IN FRONT OF US
TOMORROW. SO, OBVIOUSLY, PLEASE
PLAN YOUR FLIGHTS ACCORDINGLY.
AND TRAVEL ALSO KNOWS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE GOING COMING OUT
EARLIER TOMORROW THAN WHAT WAS
ORIGINALLY ANTICIPATED. AND
AGAIN, IT'S BASED OFF OF NOT
ENOUGH BILLS THAT CURRENTLY,
AREN'T SEEKING AMENDMENTS.
REALLY GREAT WORK THIS WEEK.
WILL BE BACK IN SESSION TOMORROW,
THURSDAY, AUGUST 22ND AT 9 A.M.
BEFORE WE ADJOURN, WE NEED TO GO
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
SENATOR ALLEN, I REALLY DO
APOLOGIZE. THIS WAS SENATOR
ASHBY'S FAULT. WE WOULD LIKE TO
ASK FOR, ON BEHALF OF SENATOR,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON, WANT TO
REMOVE AB 233 FROM THE INACTIVE
FILE. THANK YOU. SIR Þ. SENATOR
HURTADO, PLEASE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, I'D LIKE TO MOVE FILE
ITEM 342 AB 2348 BY RODRIGUEZ TO
THE INACTIVE FILE. THE DESK WILL
NOTE. IS THAT IT? OKAY MR. PRO
TEM, YOU'RE GOING TO ADJOURN US
NOW. THANK YOU SO MUCH, WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED TO SEE FOLKS
TOMORROW. THURSDAY, AUGUST 22ND
AT 9 A.M. BREAK OUT THE
GROUNDHOGS. ALL RIGHT. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
3:30 P.M, AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE TOMORROW,
THURSDAY, AUGUST 22ND, AT 9 A.M.
MEMBERS HAVE A GREAT DAY.